hello Denver [ __ ] I'm excited I want to
climb this uh Silicon Mountain we hear
about it's gonna come excited about that
first of all I have nine hundred eighty
thousand followers on Twitter I don't
want to [ __ ] the stats but I
appreciate it um I'm gonna actually
assume a lot of you don't know who I am
that's gonna where I'm gonna go with
this how many people here by show of
hands have no clue who I am please raise
it high that [ __ ] hurt I didn't mean
eighty percent all right I'm gonna take
like 90 seconds normally it's I have an
hour keynote so I'm gonna give you a
very short version of Who I am to create
context to the things I'm going to talk
about because very honestly this is a
very exciting event for me I get to
speak quite a bit but knowing that I'm
in an event that I know is going to be a
major event going forward there's
something just special about being a
keynote speaker at the first one that
you know you come back in ten years and
it's four thousand times bigger so I was
born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union I came to this country when I was
three years old I lived in a very
immigrant upbringing I lived in a studio
apartment in Queens with eight family
members the exact size of this stage so
you can imagine it was pretty tough I uh
my parents rarely bought me toys I had
to hustle for all of mine when I asked
my mom for Nintendo she said awesome go
buy it so like that's kind of like the
police I come from my first job as an
entrepreneur was when I was five I moved
to Edison New Jersey when my dad finally
got a job that paid enough for us to
move out of Queens and he was a he was a
manager of a liquor store in Clark New
Jersey when I was five I went outside
and basically started my first business
I had eight lemonade stands and I would
make all my friends work the lemonade
stands while I made the signs and try to
figure out where to put them
because I've always been following the
attention of the end consumer how many
of you remember big wheels remember big
wheels a little kind of like bike thing
I used to ride my big did you have one
[ __ ] yeah nice we got to talk about big
wheels after this talk I should ride my
big wheels around Edison New Jersey and
pick up my cash like I was little Tony
Soprano or something that was a good job
made a couple hundred bucks
twelve my entrepreneurial career really
took the next step I I started a very
big baseball card business and I was
making two to three thousand dollars a
weekend selling baseball cards when I
was 13 in the malls of New Jersey you
know I don't know about you guys but
when you have thirty thousand dollars in
cash under your bed and you're 14 and
you're not selling weed you're doing a
good job so that was good I was proud of
that that was a good start but then my
career really kind of got serious I was
14 my dad forced me into the liquor
business I was the first born immigrant
family that's just kind of how you did
it and I got paid two bucks an hour to
bag ice for 15 hours a day for two
straight years after school and every
holiday and weekend so that sucks [ __ ]
as you can imagine but it got me into
the it got me into the liquor business
when I was 16 I recognized something
that I didn't know which was that people
collected wine and that was kind of my
hook right I had this huge passion for
collecting sports cards and I had a huge
passion for helping my family business
but I didn't know how to make him hook
because it wasn't into beer or liquor
there was just no passion there but once
I realized people collected why and I
said crap you know you know silver oak
Camus Opus one same crap is Frank Thomas
John Elway and Wayne Gretzky so I took
all my passion into that and so I
started reading the bet the Wine
Spectator and Robert Parker's wine
advocate instead of Beckett baseball
card Guide and those things for some of
you that might remember I did not have a
computer in Tablas 19 years old I did
not grow up techy at all unlike many of
you in this room when I hang out with
all the cool Silicon Valley kids like
I'm going to write after here when they
start getting into that conversation of
remember your first Apple to like oh
[ __ ] nerds no let's not talk about
this you know I didn't grew up with a
modem I didn't grow up with that stuff
but I'm standing in front of you as
somebody who's had a lot of success in
tech for one reason and it's the reason
that I want to talk to you guys about
all that really matters at the end of
the day without getting real sappy up
here is human beings right you're gonna
be successful in your business I'm blown
away thinking about how many business
leaders are in here or startups company
leaders I'm blown away continuously I'm
being reminded
now because I've started running another
business I'll tell you that in a minute
of how many people underestimate that
the strength of your victories are based
on the people that work for you I am
blown away by the management style of
individuals let me let me give you one
piece of advice that I promise you and
you might not have the DNA for this but
you need to try managing with honey over
vinegar is something every single person
here needs to learn I'm baffled by
people not understanding that the people
in your organization are the backbone
and when you treat them like [ __ ] you
lose I fired in the last year the three
most talented people that work for my
social media agency because they don't
know how to play nice with the other
boys and girls please please start
giving a lot more thought to the people
that are actually building your business
which are your employees and partners
but even more importantly your customers
I'm also equally blown away by how we
think about tech for customer
acquisition and how are we gonna make
this scale SEO SEM which are Twitter get
all this forget the people that we
actually sell these products to a lot of
people in this room are tremendous
hunters you're good at getting business
but we suck [ __ ] whether we're in
Silicon Valley alley or mountain we suck
[ __ ] at farming and retaining we take
for granted who we already have so
please audit when you go home your
current clients and users and make them
feel a little bit better than just a
number I didn't grow up in tech at all
the first time I even saw a computer in
action I was already a freshman in
college I was playing Madden 94
dominating by the way and my friend came
in and said come here you have to come
and see this I will never forget this
moment he was sitting at his computer
and it was the first time that I ever
heard KooKoo Shh remember that [ __ ] AOL
three bucks a minute for some of you
youngsters paying 3 bucks a minute to
get on the Internet
those guys were [ __ ] thieves anyway
he signs on he signs on he looks up at
me I will never forget this face I will
never forget my friend Joe's face
sitting right below me he looks at me
and he goes we can get chicks on this
thing
so you went ended age sex location some
of you remember and uh and it took me
about thirty seconds that holy crap I
can sell stuff on this and it was the
first time that I ever thought I don't
need to open up eight hundred liquor
stores I don't need to come to Colorado
and compete against Apple Jacks right
and Chicago and Sam's and all that
that's when I was gonna do that's where
I was gonna do I was gonna build a
biggest liquor wine retail company in
the world and it was the first time I
said can I do it through this and so the
reason I've been relevant and the reason
I have nine hundred eighty thousand
followers on Twitter is because
intuitively I pay attention and think
about the things that you're gonna do
that you think you're not gonna do how
many people here honestly this is now
remember lying is the devil how many
people here honestly and no half-ass
Hannah I had a 4:00 a.m. wake-up call so
don't [ __ ] with me go like this how many
people here four or five years ago maybe
three said the following to themselves
or in their head did you say the
following out loud or to yourselves
please raise your hand if you did this
statement I'm not getting on Facebook
why would I ever need a Facebook account
that's for the kids
raise your hand don't lie I'm waiting
excellent got about thirty forty percent
just curious of the ones who did how
many of you are now on Facebook raise
your hand just curious actually which is
almost everybody just curious who here
is not on Facebook actually if you're
not on Facebook just cuz I want to show
the room if you do not have a Facebook
account please stand up real quick it's
good for blood circulation just stand up
for a second thank you for turning on
the lights guys let's clap it up for
these people they're fighting the
Machine good [ __ ] great shot good stuff
respect
by the way your horse is waiting for you
outside after miss keno just just the
same I launched winelibrary.com in 1996
when I didn't even know what it was I
spent fifty thousand dollars to build a
website for the company we sold two
hundred eighty six dollars worth of wine
the first year period not profit sales I
don't know how many of you have a Soviet
father but that was kind of tough the
second year we did about twenty thirty
thousand the third year we did 2.1
million I launched an email service in
1999 because my competitors were faxing
and cataloging and I did email no cost
did it often and that really grew my
business in a five year period I took my
family business from a three to a sixty
million dollar business I did it because
I thought about where people were gonna
be in 24 months not our 24 months ago I
did it because I was running a business
forever not to flip it or get it funded
or get an article in TechCrunch I did it
because I thought I was gonna be around
in 24 36 60 120 months and so I would
hustle and not pay myself to build to
where the consumers gonna go it's the
same reason I did Google AdWords when I
did Google AdWords in 2001 it cost five
cents before they did a 10 cent minimum
it cost me five cents to get the word
wine because I moved faster than all my
competitors and it was the biggest fight
ever having my dad because my dad didn't
want to do it because he was scared our
competitors we're gonna go and click our
ad and raise our bills this is what the
conversation was I let blogging go by in
2003 and for because I can't write for
[ __ ] even though I have to New York
Times bestselling books so I kind of
really believe that all of you should
think about doing what you're best at
because I think a lot of us try to do
things cuz we think they're the right
thing to do and not focusing on what we
can actually execute so I kind of let
that go but then YouTube came along and
I sat next to my developer Erik Casten
or he said check this out you've been
talking about doing wine videos but the
hosting was too expensive the first time
I ever asked a year earlier and he said
this hosts for free I started Wine
Library TV and that's kind of what
brought me into your guys world it got a
lot of recognition and I used Facebook
and Twitter to build my audience
and this time I was smart I was right
about e-commerce the first conference I
ever spoke at was one that looked like
this and the person before me said and
the kids coming up next is gonna tell
you that you're gonna buy wine on the
Internet how many people in this room
will never put their credit card into a
computer
this is 1995 by the way and every person
raised their hand so I walked out and
said this sucks and I said I wish this
was being recorded because mr.
PowerPoint that was just up here is
gonna be on the wrong side of history he
understands what's happening now but
every one of you [ __ ] will put a
credit card into a computer and I know
that because we fight technology let's
admit this this one's gonna hurt because
you're probably sitting with your
friends that think you're a tech
superstar but don't lie cuz lying is the
devil how many people here the first
time they saw Twitter thought it was the
dumbest [ __ ] they ever saw raise your
hand don't lie all weird all of you and
the reason you did was cuz we default as
business people and marketers into
saying what are we gonna say the first
time you sell Twitter you're like who
cares that I'm eating a pizza what I'm
gonna say walking the dog we didn't
think about listening right the whole
game is always countercultural
the most important website for every one
of us in this room from a marketing
standpoint in 2013 is twitter.com slash
search because we talk every warehouse
we have facebook fan pages and pin
boards and tumblr and blogs but
twitter.com slash search is the one
place that every person this room can go
and search their business their name or
the things that they're involved with
for me it was wine write and search
people talking about it you can jump
into the conversation and create the
number one word that matters to every
person in this room everybody in here is
in the content business one way or the
other if you're an API a platform no
matter what you are you're in the
content business how many people here
have heard content is king how many
people have heard that statement almost
everybody but the word that I want you
to all focus on that's the
differentiator that's the
countercultural moves going forward is
context the fact that we can build
context to set up our content is the
reason so many people are struggling
with social media the reason people
struggling with the ROI of social is
because we're all acting like 19 year
old dudes on it we're trying to close on
the first move it's all about us right
we're all pushing our stuff have you
looked at your Facebook fan page lately
it's come to this look at my this look
at this it's nothing about the community
we talk a good game collectively but we
suck at actually executing it so we need
to start doing a lot more listening not
only for our customers
definitely for our employees see a lot
of startups met a lot of people before
we need to do a lot more listening there
and we also need to recognize how
ridiculously lucky we are this is the
singular culture shift of our time this
is the biggest culture shift of our time
the internet the consumer web that we
all know is not twenty years old most
people really got on the web when
Windows 95 forced the market you're
talking about 18 years the Internet
hasn't even had [ __ ] sex yet and it's
dominating this is a very major factor
there are people in this room that are
using it but not recognizing the power
of the maturity of the internet here's
where at where the internet is at now is
we're connecting people and this is
gonna become more of a people game than
a tech game because word-of-mouth has
always been how business has been done
and now with the platforms that we all
have we have a word-of-mouth on steroids
we have an ability to create context
with end users at scale but nobody wants
to do it because everybody wants to do
something scalable it feels better to do
an algorithm it feels better to do an ad
buy let me talk to you guys about this
let me paint a real picture of it
because the one thing I know standing up
here more than the Sun comes up tomorrow
as a proud one myself is that marketers
and business people ruin everything it's
what we do and we're about to ruin
social over the next five to seven years
which is why it's so important you get
the value of it over the next three to
four do you guys remember Groupon and
LivingSocial
and that host off how many people in
this room have ever signed up for Gilt
Groupe Groupon LivingSocial how many
people here have used a deal the day
email service please raise your hand I'm
just trying to get context okay most
people do you number three years ago how
much you loved it do you remember how
you couldn't wait to get a $50 [ __ ]
spot treatment for $25 do you remember
how was the best day of your life when
you got $80 worth of sushi for $40 we
loved them just curious how do you guys
like those services now you hate them
you hate them because they pounded you
into an oblivion
they spammed you until you couldn't care
and now you don't care if they're giving
you a million dollar home for a hundred
bucks you like spam delete [ __ ] this
same thing with email 15 years ago 18
years ago you know which we loved email
I know this is a mix of a young and an
older crowd for some of the people that
are little older when email came out
it's like holy [ __ ] I have to send as
many emails as possible because they're
gonna charge for this I'm never gonna
write another letter in my life how's
the post office can stay in business
subsidies who knew but you know I'd
never written a letter but now we loved
email we made movies about it you've got
mail we loved it how do you guys like
email now you hate it we got pounded do
you know how open rates have collapsed
for marketing
do you banner ads twelve years ago the
kind of rates they were getting click
through another 0.1 we are ruining
everything step by step because it's how
we do business and right now we have
this moment in time where the consumers
are willing for you to engage with them
and create context to buy permission for
you to then market and the thing that we
don't understand as businesses is the
whole setup I'm writing a new book
called Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab right
hook and it's the thesis of this people
aren't putting in the effort people
always look at me and said how did you
get so many fans easy I spend 15 hours a
day on summize comm which was
twitter.com slash search before they
bought it and I searched Pinot Grigio
and Bordeaux and Merlot and I engaged
with people at scale do you know how
sickening it is to answer what wine goes
with fish 48 thousand times but I did it
and by the way it's not Pinot Grigio
stop drinking that [ __ ]
business is about supply and demand
because this is about supply and demand
it always is the supply and demand issue
in our world today is one simple thing
the thing that's the most limited in
supply is effort and caring and giving a
crap you know why we're busy it's a 24/7
world right
you know why the phone sucks as great as
it is is you're always on you're on it
24/7 threes
you want to get really scared watch
these hands front row watch how many
people in this room within every 24 hour
window every 24 hours including while
you're sleeping are always within arm's
reach of their telephone raise them
everybody that phone is the robot that
we were all promised but it doesn't
clean your [ __ ] room remember that in
the eighties I'm so pumped anyway we're
on 24/7 we have we're better it's nice
to see the world become better in both
you know both sexes man I think we're
doing a better job with work-life
balance women are getting better better
opportunities it's awesome but we're
busy because of it and we're always on
and so giving somebody your effort is
harder than ever and then you have
really smart people that are billing
amazing tech companies but they're smart
about it and they're looking for
efficiencies in scale
this creates a severe massive supply and
demand issue with giving a crap and I
promise you that if you audit your
business if you go home from this and
you think about all the stuff that's
going awesome in Silicon mountain and
you go home and look yourself in the
mirror and realize that you're doing
dumb [ __ ] that if you took 25% of the
dumb [ __ ] that you're doing wasting time
on doing something and you take that 25%
and you allocate that to human beings
within your world your employees and
your end customer your business will
look totally different we ran an a/b
test for winelibrary.com
where we when we call people after they
place an order bless you did when we
call people after they place an order
and we say thank you and that's it thank
you thank you for placing an order at
Wine Library com I
hope you have a great day sure what's
that
my horse I'm gonna talk to you after sir
I didn't catch my horse has a kidney
problem okay I'm gonna move on but I'm
excited to talk to that gentleman um so
we call people and say thank you and
we've a be tested all the people that
we've called and jerseys a very funny
state it's one of the few states in the
country that you can record a phone
conversation
I wondered why and and so I listened to
these calls when we call customers and
you can literally hear them waiting for
the other shoe to drop for you to say oh
and we'll give you a free shipping on
your next order or and if you buy one
more bottle and that's what we do thank
you we appreciate we're trying to scale
effort we've a be tested first-time
customers that we call versus ones we
don't and the ones we've called with
nothing else are 80% higher volume in
their purchasing and their lifetime
value is 400% longer just by giving some
form of effort the other thing we've
started doing is we're mapping on a CRM
level the individual customers on the
social web and we're watching what they
do and we've started buying things for
them as thank-yous based on their
interest graph not based on what they
buy from us so yes we know you buy
Bordeaux and Pinot Noir but now we're
understanding that you're a Broncos fan
and we may send you a jersey signed by
your favorite player which starts
creating much bigger context for the
relationship guys listen you've got a
ridiculous panel coming up here and I
could have went in a very different
direction but I thought long and hard
about who's really here the energy and
the mayor set the tone the energy here
is pretty substantial and there's a lot
of places that are doing a lot of great
things but I promise you whether it's SF
New York or anywhere else the number one
thing that is happening in our tech
industry is that we have a lot of smart
people math based science based really
smart we're doing tons of great things
and everything's really awesome but I'm
telling you we're discounting the humans
in our circle we're discounting them
thank you
we're discounting that we are
I'm stunned on how people look at their
employees as numbers and their customers
as numbers we're not putting enough
effort and I'm telling you if you want
to win in business see I'm not a
start-up person that like wrote a blog
for a little while and I went for
funding and I have a business now I've
built businesses family businesses where
every one of your customers was you died
for them because if you lost them you
were gonna be hurt we are taking for
granted the scale of the Internet that's
what it's doing for us and we're not
understanding that these companies can
grow very quickly and die very quickly
because we're not building emotional
relationships with our customer base and
our employees because we're just taking
the scale for granted we need to start
as a whole and if Denver wants to
innovate let's make this place the place
that starts innovating on not just
customer service but employee service
really start caring about the human
beings that touch your suppliers
everybody because that eco chain I
promise you if you have any interest in
building a business that lasts for 20 or
30 years instead of 20 or 30 months that
is the x-factor those are the
individuals that are gonna drive you to
that success we have to stop taking them
for granted and most importantly we have
to bought it because I'm practical I
know this is very mother Teresa and
let's hug and make out and all that but
I'm telling you right now it has to be
very practical you're busy as [ __ ]
I get it you're taking time to like I
mean I sit with my employees coast to
coast I've 200 right now
ten minutes of peace you know how are
you doing that takes time away from me
selling and making where do I get it but
it's the glue it's the foundation caring
about the end user has never been the
wrong thing as we as we all go more
jetsons the people in this room that act
like the Flintstones are gonna win thank
you
where's that dude with the horse and the
[ __ ] liver I'm coming for you